nothing stands still in this test lab
the flexible cable housing is made by
aegis company are designed to guide
electric and fuel cables to prevent
bending and damage testing is extensive
can scientists we attire vice movie
negotiable sometimes our tests just last
a few hours for example at the very high
speed in order to get an overall
assessment but the tests can also take a
long time sometimes even several years
durable plastics are used in many items
from machinery to cars and chips global
production and many of these industries
is now dominated by China the sense view
the boxes the crane sector has posted
very strong growth anything that has to
do with port cranes for unloading ships
shipping happy in Asia many huge new
ports have sprung up as a result
delegations from the sector often come
to IGAs headquarters in Cologne in 1999
the company opened a subsidiary in China
it has grown into the second largest
after the u.s. having witnessed the
market rapidly take shape and
understands the heavy dependence of
suppliers I'm kind of music for plan the
market doesn't allow us to plan far
ahead due to a lack of long-term
delivery contracts usually we plan two
to three months in advance which one we
currently aren't able to forecast beyond
that Horton lists up soon the company
also fears a snowball effect if China
reduces production that will impact its
neighbors like Japan as well even if the
Chinese economy weakens IGAs doesn't
want to pull out of the market it will
continue to invest in the country the
plan on the foolish and dims into this
view we will continue to focus on China
and expand our presence there we think
that business will continue but it
doesn't mean we have a detailed plan in
case China posts seven percent growth or
nine percent growth
for example vato da Vinci navideno
inputs and proximate so what kita
snitched IGAs can still react quickly to
changing market conditions the company
has a hundred thousand product in stock
and can deliver almost all of them
within a day that will give it an
advantage over rivals when the Chinese
economy rebounds